this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much for the generous
introduction and good afternoon everyone
thank you music so today I'm going to be
talking about my part of my PhD thesis I
call this and we're going to be looking
at contrasting environments so by way of
outline I'm going to be talking about um
cassava hopefully by now cassava is a
very familiar crop because there's a lot
of research on going in at Cornell I'll
be talking about Kosovo flowering I'll
give you an overview of my thesis and
then I'll talk about the main results
from my experiment from the part of my
work I'm sharing today and then we'll
summarize that so first of all cassava
is a big food security crop particularly
in Africa and also its use as sweets and
this is in Thailand and the export most
of this to Europe and then because the
the tuber is almost a hundred percent
starch you can see this in the
backgrounds almost 100 percent starch
it's just it has a lot of industrial
applications so this is like a sound
wave a very important curve but in
addition to this are just a little bit
about biology of cassava cassava is a
part of the e4v CIF family and it's a
perennial shrub the center of origin is
in the Amazon so that's South America I
showed you and I think it's just a fun
side of the numerous kind of things that
we can get from cassava by way of food
so this is fufu if Sabah this is very
fermented sauce we said a server and
then we can also some parts of Africa
the leaves are also used as a vegetable
like spinach cassava grows in the
tropical regions of the world and so you
see this distributed nicely the latitude
represented here and a large proportion
of that production takes place in
sub-saharan Africa and this kind of
gives you a reason why it's a huge food
security from traditionally in
sub-saharan Africa cassava is
groan as insurance against you to crop
failure because it can survive imagine
on soil so if all else fails if other
will survive so you have a green and
deciding many farmers lot this what a
plant looks like on the field I'm going
to talk some more about the pathology as
as I progress in the slides so why
cassava flowers the habitable part of
the saga is the tubers so the flowers
are not and goes as it's I said where
the reason why we leave flowers is
because of breeding so you can
well now many ways to breed right now
but flowers are important instruments so
your breeding cycle or the president
reading program rises and falls on the
availability or the success of flower so
this is why flowers are important so
it's merely because of breeding here
house lining some of the problems we
cassava flour in so as you go all
through the development of the
reproductive phases you have different
kind of program first of all the
flowering time some genotypes but
clarity once the breeders would love to
walk with is late and then if you do go
through eventually inducing flowers
development could be arrested
prematurely so an example here way
before an theses of course the flowers
are aborted well if you if you succeed
at the time and the development of
flowers the sex ratio would be another
problem there are 90 percent males
compared to females so we know that
females are going to be the seeds that
the breeders who walk with so if you if
you succeed in this too you're going to
have a problem here when you don't have
sufficient females to walk with so this
is because Kasab i said i'll cross and
species well if you succeed through one
two three you can also have problems in
arm seed said the fact that you have
females to walk we doesn't guarantee
there was set seed so the result of all
of this is your brilliance of optimal
actually you end up skill in your
brilliant to just the genotype that are
able to produce flowers you can work
with
from our studies here in the satella at
Cornell University there a number of
streams with many details about each of
these definitely that cassava is a long
big crops eight long these people are
flowering time we've also learnt about
the a special type of branch in the ice
associated with your productive
development we've also learnt about the
temperature it needs moderately cool
temperature a lot of my work focuses on
this and then we'll talk about the we've
also learned that the flourishing in as
in other species sorry no cost is
involved in regulation of flowering so
to describe what forking looks like in
cassava I have this model here I'm going
to walk you through it and show you some
description of how flowering takes place
so first of all on the on the y axis I
have the percent of branch flower this
is actually from detail just a bunch of
data and midis up with this so the
number of days to the first flowering
event could be could vary by genotype so
some could be really early some could be
very late but after the first fork in
event or the first luring event do you
have a period of vegetative growth and
then it was the second and to the toy so
I want you to keep this in mind when I
talk about here one two or three I'm
talking about flowering events the first
event second event and so on my way of
the way by way of how the plant grows
this is what it looks like so in this
particular line this is going to be any
example of a good flowering line so you
have Anisha vegetative growth and they
have this 4 PI branch in any
fluorescence in the middle so this would
be the first year then have a second
year and they can go out and so forth
some genotypes don't have as good
flowering the only succeed in just
having one flowering event and some
genotypes just never so well for us that
is why the biology on sandy biology of
cassava flooring is important because in
such genotypes there are a lot of trees
instance Ohio to whatever stall is
locked up in this kind of genotype I you
cannot include it in your breathing
cycle because we don't have flowers so
this is one of the reasons why our
studies our studies important still
giving you some details about the
morphology you might I talked about a
special type of branch and I wanted to
distinguish this from other types of
branches and according to service so you
can have lateral branches like so um but
this is different from the folk type
branches so the folk type branching is
reproductive branching with lateral
branches you can D cup you can
decapitate a plant and the buds on the
plants are activated and this is you can
get this any at any point in the growth
of casaba but this is different from the
fallpipe branch and it only happens when
the plant is transition transitioning
from vegetated reproductive phase I told
you the cassava is a long day plant from
our studies in here in Italy and this is
shown because you just support this so
you see in all across this table only as
long days do you have some flowering a
short day she really wouldn't have any
flowering and H to flower also responds
with we I told told you also that
flourishing ft is involved in Flowery
and we can see this response when we go
to the plant on the long beep condition
parts curly ft 2 is responsive to to the
long day for the pleasure so this is
where I begin my story my release it
before me a previous number of our lab
serra da mo she had already she dirty
and also in a height here eat a lot of
work on on temperature there long this
still ongoing but i'm connecting some of
my research with this thing you can see
here that at cooler temperatures you
have a lot more flowering and it's
possible that at warmer temperatures you
have no power at all you have slight
improvement in the days too flowery in
the age at which flower nor cause when
the temperature is cooler
so my PhD thesis this is like a lot of
things to a lot of information to walk
with and like I kind of decided that I'm
going to contribute in three phases I'm
going to look at the biotic environments
to look at the flows of hormones in this
and also and hope that would give us
some information anticipatory for today
I'm only focusing on the a biotic
environment disordered so I hope you're
compromised next time in there and then
we'll give you more information about
them historically in imagine there's
been this story that there are two
locations in Nigeria and would be Aceh
and the dogma is everything they take in
here Jeff flowers so breeding programs
both from IIT knee button from DK they
come to OPI Jamaica crosses because for
reasons which no uncle to say previously
the viatra environments people slurry
and this is some of the she circled each
I was able to lay my hands on and you
can see that VR is earlier and then if I
don't in terms of a flurry so my job my
interest was to find out what the
underlying biology in the students had
my environment interaction was and also
to hopefully that will provide us some
insight that we can begin to suggest
ways to intervene and to improve cassava
flour what I did was so from IIT a
maintains a 700 Jeannette public unified
population called the genetic game
population and I selected genotypes
based on the data that they had in in
three categories so genotypes that were
between 30 and 60 days like mitosis by
any category my meat category used was
sixty to ninety days and my life
category which unifies are over 90 days
of 100 genotypes so I thought I made a
sub selection I planted these
simultaneously in both location and I
observed the physiology of the plant and
also I was collecting detail in the
environment
the first thing is temperature and 17
what we learned is if I don't
consistently led a piace in temperature
so if Adam was a warmer location notice
in month one and in the fourth months
you have like this huge difference in
the 10 well maybe not huge but you have
a difference in the temperature maximum
temperature so I want you to hold bear
that in mind I was also able to collect
rainfall data and OPI Chad turns out to
be wetter than possibly explaining
White's father I wanted to remember that
my Jo is a tropical country so day
length is not a factor because Lillian
doesn't change as much so I'm the only
reason why it will be cooler is not also
snow but because of rain so from
physiology of the flood the looking at
plant height as a index for plant growth
locations indeed the plants grew better
anybody on compared to OB Aceh and I
just wanted to remind you that from the
previous slides we talked about the
weather and he by donors warmer but it's
not drought stress so there's sufficient
rainfall - should I snow drought stress
and so it's possible that the growing
conditions in a bedroom c4
photosynthesis so you have more body
mass production and like that is why
diagnosis as much money in this sub
panel was also true for should biomass
and good sweet but I'm not trying that
yeah
however we don't see any advance
fortunately by environment interaction
because the same rank
maintains sort of the same around 20 D
and E bada except for the few genotypes
is kind of maintained in OB address
but in flowering time the story is
slightly different so I used number of
notes 214 because this is a kind of a
developmental time score in our redox is
used number of Rosetta leaves 2 as an
inch as an index for the age at which
that flower so I use a number of
Northfork and partly because these
doesn't change its kind of the timing so
however whenever you come to score it's
when when to come it is determined so it
was a much more objective I'm trying to
use them the chronological age of the
plant and so we see the genotype by
environment interaction being how it
plays out here for some is strong for
some it's not so much and all genotypes
were earlier they would be a joke that
even bother on supporting historical
data that we had that OVR genotypes are
usually earlier in the area but like I
said some of them the way there was
almost no difference like they were
almost on top of each other so it's was
almost identical in the two location in
turns out that these this genotypes that
were that behave this way happen to the
G to be the genotypes I have selected to
be in my any category looking at this I
either I compared the two locations and
I was asking the question whether some
genotype whether this change was really
significant or not and this place the
genotypes in two categories a category
which I'll describe as plastic and these
genotypes was in current difference and
we need the change and time to flowery
notes the location was significant where
I stood that I would describe as
non-plastic which the change was not a
significant I want to pause here to
define the system just in the interest
of those who may not be biologists as
the response of the offer of living
organism to the environment and so the
plastic genotype
means that they are responding
it's the environment while the non-toxic
genotype so may be insensitive to the
environment the result I saw from my own
study made me to go back to the
historical data I had access to from
evidence so this was data collected in
between 2013 and 2015 and I wanted to
see how I didn't have miss 214 because
that was something I introduced when I
started my own study but instead I had
the correct chronological ages of the
plants and what we see what I did here
was essentially to take the difference
between the basic flooring of the
ginning days of flowering Al Pacino
Tyson if I go piatra and most of the
genotypes were later in if I don't some
of them were stable and all non-plastic
were a few of them where the reverse
direction the non stable line I if I
defined my threshold for stability as
lines that had no more than three days
difference in their flowering silently
22 locations so this is like something
like a way for me to begin to think
about the biology of what is going on in
two locations not just and one location
is earlier than the other but to see
that there there is this interaction
with the environment at each of the
Chilean ties can behave differently so
zooming in more detail I took her
representative member of the plastic
group and a representative member of the
non plastic group and on the on your on
your left hand you have the data from
number of notes but what I'm showing
here is something a little more advanced
beyond just the time to initial flower
flower induction we have here what
happens over the course of three years
so for the first unit I'd this genotype
which is the same as the non faster
genotype you see that the pattern of
flowering is similar and the two
locations at the same but in the toxic
genotype the passion of flowering for
the three tier so this is Tier one two
and three
you have this different at the same time
if you compare each of the genotypes in
vertically so like we can add each
location separately you see that it's
Ruby Aceh in which is a favorite
favourable environment has a similar
pattern in the plastic and sorry in the
non elastic and the plastic genotype
suit I'm taking that to sort of reflect
what is going on here that there's a
sort of a core vengeance or similarity
between the two genotypes in viata
but if you look at the other direction
the unfavorable location you can see a
huge difference um if I should talk say
more about this moving the the time to
move from one flowering event or like
one tier to the other in the unfavorable
environment expands and also the
proportion of plants that came from her
from that are able to have subsequent on
reproduction reproductive phases is gets
the one eventually completely shut down
in a plastic genotype so this was a
interesting thing that excited to dig a
little more into the biology of this but
before this out from the genotypes I had
on the field I sheep the number of them
to eat the cup so that we could do
control studies on those and with Peters
help I was able to get this running so
this on the few days these are genotypes
from the field silk and walk you through
slowly so you have the plastic the blue
and orange line represents our plastic
genotypes those that respond to the
environment while the Green Line is
representative
non-plastic genotype under growth
chamber or under control conditions we
had a three temperatures 20 to 28 and 34
degrees daytime temperature and you see
us
as well this resembles the field a lot
that the plastic genotypes and the field
were very very temperature responsive so
meaning that as the temperature got
higher the we had aced the flowering the
time to flowering also increased for
Anton non-plastic genotype was almost
temperature and sensitive of course you
I know you might say oh they didn't fall
it well exactly the same pattern the
blue is not quite as because the orange
in both location but it's just when I
get to begin to like how questions think
about what is happening on the field so
remember the field is not just one you
cannot reduce the field conditions to be
just temperature but this there's there
this is kind of showing evidence that
the thing going on and the field might
be temperature related in addition to
this previously from our lab we had also
done a previous number of our lab Sarah
de Meaux she had over expressed our
adaxes ft in cassava and she we found
out that improved flowering so I took
the which of the two genotypes in
question so the wild-type 6:04 four
points south american line and it's a
late flowering genotype well in this i
hope after this presentation we would
redefine what late means the late would
be in reference to a particular
environment and also the while the
transgenic plant which is the which
carries the expression of ft and just
like before the later like oh the
wild-type had a lot of that's the city i
want to draw your attention to fact that
this horizontal line here doesn't mean
that it no longer responded to
temperature it's just because in the
growth chamber we couldn't grow beyond
180 days so we have to truncate the
experiment so that's why so it's
possible if we have enough space and
kept it going we could have seen this
line further than these whereas the
overexpression line was sort of
insensitive to the temperature
so based on this information I propose
two models of what is going on in Java
which respects it that's the city my
first module I'm suggesting that in a
non-plastic genotype a lot depends on
the genetics of the plant itself while
the environment contributes very little
rice hypothesis is that in the non
classic genotype sufficient flora gene
or flowering stimulus is produced such
that the environment wasn't affected
much so if in the the quantity of
fluorine that it produces able to
counteract the anti flaw region so it's
able to progress to develop a to
flowering time independent of the
environment paradoxes there is a the
autonomous flowering pathway and I can't
begin conversations about how this my
collectibles whereas in the plastic
genotype flowering time depends heavily
on the environment to facilitate the one
of three things the environment can
either increase the floor region such as
in the favorable environments increases
law region so that is able to counteract
the entire origin and then have
flowering time whereas the on paper
environment may not do that we can also
do the reverse it might be that it's not
just a flourishing to the flowering
stimulus that is changing but the
suppressant does the surprise Center
flowering so that's the anti flow region
and also we can also propose that the
two are changes so we provide a
favorable environment a lot of storage
units produced flourishing but in the
reverse happens so this is sort of my
what I'm proposing to that is
potentially going on in the plastic and
plastic genotype
but Sara also in a lot of had already
done some studies on temperature and she
was previously I showed you that ft was
the ft 2 in particular what particular
was a responsive to for a few years who
have long days you've had more ft
production so she was also interested to
see how temperature affected this ft and
I want to connect what she eat to some
of what I'm finding and in the stable
line we don't have any evidence that the
temperature is affecting the ft
expression in the correct direction
because at lower temperature you should
expect higher ft to warmer temperatures
it's possible that I'm speculating that
because this line is a as a non-plastic
line it doesn't depend on the
environment and sodium the body
environments is doing to the energy
expression you may or may not have any
bearing on the phenotype which is
flowering time whereas in the plastic
genotype in well TM the ft one there is
no evidence for flow for the for the
there's no evidence that this is some
temperature responsive but ft2 shows
some we can argue about how strong this
evidence is but at least there is some
evidence that at cooler temperatures
there a higher FG ft2 expression
compared to one more temperature this is
just the aspect we have for chlorogene
but we don't have any information on the
anti flora Jane so I was interested in
doing a more global study usually to
genotype so that we could get some
information and the authorities as well
as the origin so just quickly what I do
when people are
I see what I really suggest is a whole
Expo genome expression profile and also
communication and education of the vote
transcript we used our three primary six
method which was cost effective and
irony is
those two is a reverse transcribe to
cDNA and then we sequestered refine and
I also want to remind you quickly that
Ibadan was in February location and
earlier the the temperatures in weather
is warmer than the air check and this is
what I did I had two genotypes a plastic
representative plastic and non plastic I
had an unfavorable occasion I favored
location I took two time points so one
was my representative juvenile face
thirty days after planting and then I
took seven days after fourth and so at
this stage where I will show that
flowering or transition to production to
productivity or extra tonight RNA
Nigeria ship it if the cup needs some
more processing like purification and so
on a sequence that biotech with the help
of year how and hue I would say we got
some of the statistics ongoing and this
is double centered PCA methodology which
you can get more information about how
that is done but basically on the on the
main contrast is shown on the abscissa
on the x-axis and we see the suppress
socially now between the two genotype in
the blue genotype we see that the tulipe
the open versus the closed open vessels
the closest separated into two different
segments of the of the TCA how about the
well she mention that the double
centered PCL walked through the
interactions not just in the individual
and I so the interaction of the samples
and the chains and other expression
values and we see that is a clear
sorting so meaning that in this genotype
us as we've seen and in the phenotype of
the question into the links clear
distinct
behavior of the location so
on all of the Bajorans and all of the
theaters we need two different
components whereas the non-plastic
genotype we didn't have that clearly
socket but what is seen is that non
facit genotype which makes sense because
if you sample up to different ages you
expect to be different you can also add
the food change I took to illustrate
what is going on just for the purpose of
the seminar at seven days was 14 which
is when the trend had transitioned to
productive says you can see that in the
non plastic ties between the two
location there's very need to change in
the expression the the two whereas a lot
of difference in signal so this is these
are things that we can even begin to
begin further to look at what is
happening what pathways are involved and
so on so I'm going summarize right now
and I saying that on the field the the
plasticity and the response agenda by
Vera interruption we see on the field is
related to cool temperature and actually
favoring flowering is related to cooler
temperature and we've also seen that at
cooler temperatures of sorry time on
pages irrespective of the genotype a
classic didn't like warmer temperatures
delayed flowering and when there's high
expression of F T we are able to reverse
this buses plasticity our gene
expression profile shows is able to
distinguish the plastic from the non
toxic and this is something I'm still
going to looking more details are warmer
temperature might stimulate the
expression of the anti Floridian which
might explain to us the spiritual saying
it's not the end of my PhD
I talked about I told you that I'm doing
the today I'm focusing on them but a
biotic environment and I'm going to do
much more work on this in the days
coming and then I'm going to complete um
another scientific interpretation of
this on the site a tiny and sugar status
I want to acknowledge the many people
who have helped in India this slide does
not do justice to all the people who
have helped me at the cost of my journey
and I want to acknowledge my peer to
comity the members of our lab both
present and past I had a lot of help
from Li Hao and here on the RAC data
analysis my collaborators in Nigeria I
had a wonderful field team particularly
yemassee my healer system was become
more than just an assistant who is much
more like a friend and a lot of
undergrads helped me with my big scoring
well this doesn't catch all of them I
had several rounds of awakening I had a
small grants welcome don't underestimate
what small grants can do to your
research and then fund enough received
from IITs support by field spaces next
gen to the build I'm in the Gates
Foundation and of course the Government
of Nigeria so actually going is how we
say thank you indicated that the
flowering even says that the flowering
Sparrow is learn you have any sub
positions as to why my pictures there's
more inductive being produced and this
is able to counteract my permit from an
evolutionary perspective while how would
something like that know about all this
what do you think the thing is that's in
the environment that encouraged that
siloed that's striking you know asking a
lot so I'm looking at a tropical sea she
yeah
one way you could think about it is that
the cooler temperature is not favorable
for the plant and so it means
facilitates the production so that it's
life is well it continues succeeded in
the environment so like 20 cents is that
it's nothing like let's quickly produce
so that we can continue our lineage but
that's what tropical plants in our
temperate species you have the
realization which is sensing when winter
is going to end so that reproduction can
take place so that's the way I think
about it that it's everything a plant
would do is to save all its reproduction
and so if it noted that something is
going to affect its succession it would
quickly reproduce before stress response
I don't like we have masters of eight
lines there's a bad year year after they
have no findings of seed so you think
it's not something long not maybe just
if you look at winter versus spring it's
just that the resources that are going
to be available in spring is going to be
our border so we need to start so we can
make the most of the resources available
not really that we are scared that we
realize that's the way I'll think about
it maybe no such a sovereign manage
rather than avoiding problem well you
know yes I have this thought that it's a
win rings when wings about
when brain begins my thought is also
somewhere along the line that there's
more abundance of water
so we can with the floods can't
distribute : or growth is going to be
improved and so on so goes up my
differential between I'm trying to think
about what that would yeah with all of
these genotypes have been in the
sequence for kids I kind of detail
well the days of flowering is not
something that the readers next-gen you
probably knew there was a G was of
flowering thing that was done at some
point soon some of that they did they
look or low-sided specifically
interacted with location I got were
affected by this from a study we had a
lot of small effect details and we
spread out so much flowering is the
environmental traits like everybody's
[Music]
the foundation and see
okay so I actually have one experiment
in which I looked at that study and I
have my speculation based on my result
is that it's sort of independent I know
you're thinking about potatoes because
the florigen signal influences
civilization as well as our induction
but remember that potatoes is a modified
stem or as cassava is our true root and
also the phloem the way the film is
arranged in the and the stem is not
quite the same as in the roots FG
produced and transported through the
floor and so those are kind of where my
thoughts are going but my Alicia kind of
suggests this but not conclusive
questions
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu